hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very excited to have the absolutely
lovely ava capri with us today she is an
actress she is a potential future
therapist who hear all about it you
might know her as lucy on the second
season of love victor and the upcoming
third season uh you might know her from
her friend group of internet buddies
including but not limited to her
girlfriend alexis chisel uh we talk
about her
uh fourier into acting in childhood how
her parents kind of uh took her out of
the industry for a bit how she got back
into the industry the things she thinks
about the industry the impact of a show
like love victor which you can watch on
hulu and everything in between she's
absolutely lovely and incredibly
insightful so please enjoy this episode
of not too deep with eva capric
[Music]
ava
hello
first question yes
what was the first thing you did this
morning when you woke up
um what did i do this morning i um
i checked my phone but i'm normally not
like that but it's because
i had plans with a friend um
this morning which is the first thing in
the morning for me yeah yeah crack of
dawn
uh
and then yeah and then i met up with my
friend so you checked your phone but you
said you're normally not like that is
that so you're a person that wakes up
and doesn't look at your phone right
away because i have that terrible habit
and if you have tips on breaking it
please let me know a person that like
likes to like pretend and also like
thinks a lot about being the type of
person that doesn't like yes same i
spent a lot of time like thinking about
it um
have i like over a extended period of
time accomplish it no
but i'm like really proud of myself for
like all the thinking about it
yeah that's what they say that's how you
manifest right it's like you just like
think it into existence
um okay so ava for people that don't
know let's say hypothetically you meet
an alien has no idea who you are but
they want to know what it is that you do
how do you describe
what you do
oh um
i just like play around um for money
it's like really ridiculous and really
wonderful uh
yeah i don't know i guess i pretend to
be other people
uh with other people and then they
record it and then people pay money for
that that's incredible incredible now
uh i think they call that acting yeah
some some do
how did you end up there how did you get
into that world
um i did some acting when i was like
really young like i was on a couple
episodes of like a soap when i was five
and things like that when you were five
years old yes
do you have memories of that yeah
i have a very distinct i was like five
or six and i did this pilot that never
got picked up but it um
shot in front of a live studio audience
and
i have this memory and my dad like also
has told me it from the other side but
i'd like definitely remember it first
person in a way but i was like really
young and i was wearing this like little
pink dress and we just i think finished
taping the first i think the pilot
episode and i played like one of the
main characters little daughters but he
like lifts me up and is like walking me
along like this crowd of like cheering
people
and my dad told me it like totally
freaked him out because he's like oh no
like that's bad and you could i was like
loving it because i was five
it was a really intense moment i
remember being lifted up and then like
simba
so much attention and like all the stuff
my parents were like
so they took me out of acting around
that age actually
that's i mean yeah if there's going to
be a moment uh that is visually like a
red flag of like how do we cut this off
at the head right now that might be it
yeah they were like nervous and the show
didn't get picked up and they wanted to
just like put me in school and so they
kind of did that and like i wasn't
really available for auditions because
they put me in like regular school
gotcha
yeah so wow it's great too if you have
that first-hand memory that your dad was
able to confirm that that wasn't like a
fever dream that you just made up
totally yeah i mean it was it's really
interesting but it's the only one
luckily okay so i do think it is really
rough for
children because i think if that would
have kept going on yeah very the center
of attention you're only around adults
yeah you're amazing you're amazing and
then the show ends the show gets
canceled and then it turns off you know
and it's very
hard i think for
for kids to wrap their heads around that
yeah and very noble of your parents to
kind of like remove you from that
situation because acting in
entertainment i'm curious your thoughts
on it in general is like an emotional
battlefield all the time of
loving you know the play of it all and
becoming different people but constantly
putting yourself out there
yeah definitely and i think that there's
as an adult or like actors that i know
that have like kind of made it
as an adult like they're really grateful
yeah um because i think that you
understand what's going on a lot more
and i think that the confusing like
i think kids understand play and like
what's imaginary and stuff
but they can't understand the nuances of
like
you're getting a lot of attention right
now but it's about to end or it could
end at any moment and that's normal and
then you know what i mean and it's like
totally yes that's a really rough thing
yeah yeah the fleetingness of like the
emotional like stimulation is so hard to
process even as an adult let alone as a
child for sure yeah so you went to a
regular school regularly
and then when did you start kind of
coming back into entertainment
i um
so i was like 14 or 15 and when i was
younger my parents i still did some
commercials when i was younger and i
made
some good money doing commercials when i
was younger yeah
and uh i was like i need to make money
like i should do commercials again
so i went home obviously um obviously
i'm like how much i made as a kid and i
was like i should do that again and i
was like it's time for me to make money
and she was like okay and i got a
commercial agent and like booked the
first audition i went on and i very
quickly like was booking commercials
pretty easily
and i was like this is so easy like just
i want to do more like
tv movies um my mom's like okay but
that's like really different and also
really hard and you're gonna have to
take class and like take it seriously
um
and i was like okay like sure
and i went to class and then it was
really uh hard and i think that hooked
me the fact that it wasn't
um like commercials are very like you
just be yourself and you smile and you
turn to the side and it's like but um
the like
the fact that like acting is
theatrical and like um acting is a lot
different i think the challenge and me
kind of being like struck by it is the
thing that like made me really sink my
teeth into it in a way
um
and like yeah then it and then here we
are today here we are today i mean yeah
because there is
i think that might be like the
misconception that so many people have
that don't work in entertainment that
they see it as this like fluffy thing
that like pretty people go and do and
they make lots of money doing it but
when you do take it seriously it's
really complex or it can be if you
decide to treat it that way yeah and you
have to really dig deep and um i mean if
you do it the right way you know like
it's just a very i remember
you know i think growing up everyone you
know you certain walls of like emotions
and things and vulnerability and i think
i really struggled early on
being vulnerable in a certain way and i
remember
just like having teachers being like
yeah if you want to act you like
absolutely need to become like raw and
vulnerable
things hit you
and i think that really stuck with me
and i i do feel like today i am an
extremely like sensitive person in a
positive way like
because
as actors were required to like stay
sensitive to the world um
if you're a dentist you can just be
closed off and like
you can be pretty emotionally stunted in
all other areas but
i think that's why i'm hyper fascinated
by actors that do take it seriously
because i do struggle with like making
myself vulnerable and people that can
just put themselves fully into something
and be
sensitive and raw and affected in real
time by things that are
made up it's wild to me
okay so then
you go from taking classes and then you
start going on like auditions yeah
uh what's that process like for you at
first
um
so i did like this showcase this like
agent manager showcase and i got my
managers that way okay and it started to
go on a few auditions and then i started
to get like my original agency like
wouldn't even like say that they were
wrapping me they're like
send you on some auditions and we'll see
how it goes okay um and then i started
to like get really good feedback and i
remember
i got like close to a few things um when
i was still in high school which was
hard because my high school at the time
was like if you want to which is rare
for la high schools that they're like
you want to be an actor like leave this
school like we will not accommodate you
whoa oh like any of that something and i
was also very
involved in the school at the time um
and like just like student council and
like sports and so many things so i was
very busy but i was like sneaking in
some auditions
um
yeah and i just started to get like
close to things um when i was like young
like 16.
um i remember my first callback was for
awkward the show
yeah yeah it was like a chem read with
beau mercoff and
i was like so nervous but apparently it
went well but they said i looked way too
young
to play next to him oh no
but yeah but it was the those casting
burgers are really sweet and they've
cast me in other things but like uh it's
it was just
i was
gonna go to college and i had a lot of
plans and then
i just kind of kept going with this
thing and by the time
it was college time i was like i think i
wanna
do this for a little bit longer and see
what happens yeah yeah myself in a way
um yeah good for you
did
what were the college plans were you
gonna major in theater or acting or
anything like that no like i probably
like psychology honestly film time um
build more psychology and those are
still my interests um
but yeah i wasn't gonna and even now
like i talked to a lot of actors like a
lot of acting programs at schools are
very like theater driven
and sometimes don't always apply to
getting work um
in film and television yeah i am also
you know to a degree because i mean most
of the actors that i love have gone to
wonderful
um cool acting school so i think it just
depends really
yeah i mean it also makes sense that you
would have an interest in psychology
because you have to get into the brains
of characters and understand how and why
they're affected by different things at
different times in their lives um is
there still
a backup
a therapy really really yep i would
absolutely like i'm waiting for me to
like something happen need to be done
with acting and then i'm gonna go be a
therapist yeah wow
wow okay see i've toyed with this idea
but i
i've recognized that i can't do it
because i can't keep a secret about
other people's
i mean like to be like illegal like
exactly which is why i'm like i know my
limits but also i think i would take on
too much of the emotional
stuff from other people and wouldn't
have healthy boundaries for myself in
the process um but i am i can't wait let
me know when you get your office and i
will sign up as a client immediately
it's funny because
before i came on this uh like not too
deep and i understand like that this
show is not too deep yeah point of it
but
i'm
i tend to like sometimes like i love
like going deep and you know what i mean
happiness i'm like i feel like i'm gonna
break the rules of the podcast no no no
the podcast has been going on for like
six or seven years now and that's how it
started but like all good humans it has
grown and evolved and has gotten in
touch with its deeper sentiments so you
can go as deep as you would like because
that's also the world that stimulates my
brain now too
um okay going back a little bit to the
acting world now so
let's talk about love victor
how did this happen
talk me through it
okay so love victor i actually um
funny story is i tested for
the character of mia in season one okay
thank god i didn't get it because rachel
hilson is the best person ever um and
but i i've heard that the producers
really loved me and a lot of stuff and
i'm like okay
um and then funny enough there was like
a small role in the end of the first
season that they offered just offered to
me and i'd never like just been offered
a role before so i was like oh that's
exciting and i was like not working at
the time but it was a kind of like
really one-off role and i was like
my agents were like i don't know
i think we kind of landed on like okay
well they're like well if they like you
so much they can write you something
better you know maybe you've got
something better
and i was like okay and i was like
really probably wanted the money at the
time a lot yeah but i said no
um because it was such a small role and
then when season two writing was
happening uh my team got a call from
them saying we have this role we think
ava
um might be a match for it and then i
taped and
and then i booked it yeah incred again
gambling on yourself situation important
to do that and like trust your good and
just because like you have an
opportunity in front of you
you need to take it like if something
feels off about it that yeah it's huge
and that's just like i this is a story
about my girlfriend funny enough you
might know my girlfriend alexis g zone
of course i know your girlfriend i
didn't want to say anything if it wasn't
a comfortable territory to talk about
worse no no she's so excited that i'm
here right now like
are you i i just know like her early in
her youtube career like you were just
like such like an inspiration for her
and like really
like when she was making videos um she's
since retired but
good for her good for her oh i envy that
anyway she was stoked that this is
happening and i also i'm stoked sweet i
mean yeah cause she also i'm sure you
guys have a lot in common of sharing the
common ground of like working in and
around this industry for the last like
decades two decades of your lives um
so
with especially a show like love victor
and especially with you being out and
having a girlfriend all these things the
show is extremely important to like a
generation that now gets to see more
representation in all kinds of ways
on tv on big screens on little screens
on their you know phones
how has the reception been how's the
experience been for you
it's so sweet like it is such a sweet
hopeful show like
the tone of the show is
so sweet and it will make you cry like i
cry and all and i read the episodes
before and then i watch them and i cry
oh cool just because like uh anna ortiz
who plays victor's mom is such an
incredible actress and like those scenes
between them
always get me
um
but it's so amazing that this is like
such like it been a successful like
popular show and like i love
what it's about in it the way that they
do it
it's just like a lot of heart and um
yeah it's really really cool and also
like i know a lot of
much like not teenager uh people like
older men their 50s and 60s gay men who
really love the show because they watch
it
and they think about like you know if
they would have had something like this
and just like kind of reliving that and
this like hopeful tone and uh it's
really cool that's yeah that's um
almost too overwhelming to like accept
all of the gratitude and all the
appreciation but also just so cool that
things are moving in that kind of
direction
you've played straight parts and you've
played gay parts do you approach them
differently at all
no really
like my secret i used to say when i
would like play
when when i do play like i don't even
want to say straight part but when i my
romantic interest is a man yeah my
character is bisexual you know what i
mean oh yeah yeah because i i i like to
bring myself to
um and i've dated men before you know
scandalous yeah scandalous
all the papers um but like i
like to keep a little bit of
like authenticity and so i think that
when i do that and i think it's just
like is more real and then you're not
like
i know acting is pretending but there's
not there is like a more genuine aspect
to it then yeah you're playing a
character versus a caricature of
something yeah and people are nuanced
and things and i think it's nice to
bring
that nuance and like make choices like
that yeah totally okay we're gonna take
a quick break uh when we get back i
guess what i have a billion more
questions for you so we'll be right back
we're not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here in this not too deep world
we've built and you'd like to leave us a
review that would be so wonderful if you
can go to the itunes store the app store
and leave us a lovely little review
comment how are you feeling good bad
otherwise maybe just good or otherwise
would be appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay now speaking of you know your
girlfriend has worked in content
creation a lot of your uh friend group
seems to be content creators um
what was your first impression
of that kind of
lifestyle honey you ask um i think
when i first met alexis i was at a point
in my life with social media was like
obviously much newer
four years ago uh than it is now
especially
like
social media people
doing different things you know what i
mean and yeah like
i mean i'll start from the beginning
because my my thoughts have changed but
i was definitely like
you know influencers who would do acting
roles i feel like
they don't they're not even spending the
time in acting class you know yep and uh
it was just a world that i didn't know
really much about i think i'm 26 and
like like 1995 like i'm a zillenial
um
uh but i think that like
a little bit younger than me like there
was so much more like tapped into that
world
and so basically when i met elastis
i
was like the fact that she was a
youtuber like kind of made me nervous
yeah and i was like i don't know about
that um anything about this like seems
intriguing but also
yeah there's a bit of cringe that comes
with it but i don't know i shouldn't be
judging in any way
cool like the thing is once i'm like oh
my god she's so hard-working and so
talented and you really like run your
own business and it's like
very cool and now i have so many friends
who've like come up in the content
creating room and still are or used to
be
and like i think they're so cool like i
think and they work so hard and i think
and a lot of them are like starting to
do different things like my friend
claudia just started a movie um that is
going to be amazing um
and like she's been acting for a long
time but i think that like
these people that have working like
content creation people want to pitch
and hold them in some way sometimes
um
and
and it's so ridiculous because people
are so multi-faceted faceted and
talented
anyway i honestly i think people in that
world are the coolest now there you go
well it's one of those it's a world
that's like ever evolving because i
still have a viewpoint that and i have
to kind of like you know
360 my view on all of it that it is a a
business it is a career path now and
it's uh when i started it was still
getting carved out and now it's like
carved and continues to be carved in
different ways by really like innovative
creators that you truly can't like the
great creators you can't pigeonhole to
one specific thing
and you can only like
appreciate like you're saying how hard
working everyone is in that world
because you could work 24 hours a day if
you wanted to
yeah and you shouldn't because it'll
burn you out so quick
well with that i'm curious how do you
approach your social media then because
you are so effervescent and looking at
like your social media profiles you seem
to have a very like um
uh a mysterious kind of heir to you on
there is that purposeful
sort of it's funny my like friends have
been saying that a lot recently too and
like uh
sort of
i also
started to become afraid of instagram in
a weird way same preach to the choir
yeah seriously it makes me a little
nervous it makes my butthole tight just
a little bit yeah
and i don't know why and i look back at
like my instagram in high school and i
was like i was free and having so much
fun and it was actually around the time
that i started getting strangers
following me from my just being
associated with my friends who
create content um
and that started to make it it changed
it changed my relationship with it for
sure
um where it wasn't just like posting
silly stuff for my friends which i would
love to get back to that because i look
at instagrams that i love
yeah they're just
free
um so i i like to not force post so i
almost never published
[Applause]
so that's the mystique
i'm with you that's i feel like the i
just overthink it so much to a point
that like it seems so much a part of
your job in a crazy way that's just the
truth yeah and i've tried to like back
off from it because same as you that
like you get these very toxic thoughts
and you get these very like deep anxiety
ridden associations with it and like the
pressure
that truly you're only putting on
yourself but it feels inherent and like
baked into the platforms themselves so
it's like yeah if i wake up on a good
day i have a great relationship with it
and
those days are uh rare
in that sense you know yeah
um
okay
well with that you also have a really
cool sense of style that i
really
i mean we're both sitting here in
t-shirts and so i really appreciate it
how do you describe your sense of style
ugh i've never done that before so
never had to do that um i don't know i
like to be comfortable like i have these
like jeans that i bought for like four
euros when i was
in europe
i was like literally on the street um
they have a giant butthole i don't know
if i'm allowed to show this
but it was a little smith
much smaller than it is
that did seem to seem but i still wear
them because they're so comfortable and
i love them um so that's my fashion
sense is that it's great eventually by
spring they'll become shorts and you
won't need to buy any booty shorts
though i've retired the booty shorts
um
but yeah i know i i like i don't know i
feel like honestly like after coming out
i started to like
get
like
i don't know i just like like
clothes and i like dressing the way i
like and i think
i look cooler after that because i think
i got more confidence i think that's i
mean that's really great to hear because
i
i i think there's probably like a stigma
and a pressure on like young actresses
to dress a certain way that you know
showcases their bodies in a like time
capsule of the age that you're in kind
of thing
and i've always been of the mindset of
like dressing for comfort over
like other people's sex appeal ideas of
me and so yeah very in love with your
style yeah i think it's just like if i
think it's cool then it let goes and i
think that's like
how it should be you know what i mean
the life motto yeah exactly um okay so
you've done comedy and drama you did
like a sports action film is there a
genre that you haven't tapped into yet
that you'd like to work in
hmm
i haven't done like this out
there's this like
kind of like want i would love to do
like dark comedy thoughts mm-hmm
um
i love that
i did a film this summer
that
i think will have dark comedy undertones
okay um we'll be on netflix in june cool
under what name i don't know maybe do
revenge
but it
but i i can even go darker like i love a
really dark dark comedy like
i feel like that's just
uh out of context quote you hear in
therapy i could go darker
if you want me to go darker
um yeah
that's wonderful uh
okay i'm gonna move on to the two
questions ask every single guest that is
on the podcast uh the first is who alive
or dead would you most like to throw
cold spaghetti at oh
cold spaghetti um
let's see here
um
wow um
probably
hmm
this is hard
you know
um
so
most people probably think that's a bad
thing
well it's entirely up to you i like to
also add that it's up to your intention
it can be a fun thing if you want it to
and the answer that you give now isn't
necessarily the answer that you'll have
tomorrow it's just in this moment right
now who might come to mind
okay yeah
um i'm
i don't know why i'm weirdly thinking of
there's a man in my life his name is
bill wells and he was a family friend
okay so funny and cool like and
um help me like
he's so smart too and he helped me write
my college essay like he just edited
help me edit it and he was so cool and
he passed away a few years ago cancer
and i would love to see him and so i
would love to do that and then we could
laugh about it or something like that
that's very sweet
that went in a direction i didn't expect
that went
on all different detours that i wasn't
expecting
uh i don't know if that's how you answer
that
it's beautiful
okay the other question i ask every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pant [ __ ] story
or or like a bathroom emergency
situation um but you can only use three
words or like a series of small phrases
to describe the situation mine for
example is college jogging front lawn
nice yeah um
mine is um
soccer practice okay
question mark
question mark um
like chain restaurant bathroom like
i know i broke the rules no no no that's
perfect
i feel like that's what most chain
restaurant bathrooms are meant for yeah
bathroom emergencies
uh okay now we have a section of the
podcast called deep and hot where i ask
you a deep question
uh and then i'm gonna ask you for your
hot take on um kind of like a topic that
we have for you
so deep question is
why
do you think people want to label you so
much
to understand me
yeah i think well i think labels help
just like brains understand things
and obviously that can be negative
because people are
so many things sure when you label them
one thing you can like section them off
and so yeah so the reason it's done is
to understand
but in the attempt to understand we
actually miss what is there i think um
slapping too many labels on
that's very profound thanks i love that
uh on that note your uh the hot take is
well kind of chew well no one uh just
hot take on therapy
oh
i love it that's not all it takes
i know we're like in a very pro therapy
moment in culture which is very bizarre
because therapy's been around forever
but yeah we're in a very introspective
time i think where it's very trendy to
work on your mental health which is
incredible like think about all the bad
trends there are true
so yeah i don't know i'm really lucky i
grew up with two parents who
had pretty rough childhoods and deeply
therapized themselves
or like in therapy my entire childhood
and
i think that was really great for me and
i had lots of friends whose parents
wouldn't come close to therapy with like
a thousand yard stick um i think they
suffered because of that i think
that i'm just incredibly grateful that
my parents were
always
like really pro communicating and
talking about feelings and really had
the tools to be able to do that because
they were
working on themselves constantly yeah
yeah i don't know that's not a hot take
but go to see a therapist the healthiest
people i know
are in therapy and the people that i
worry about the most are not in therapy
so that's my take is like
healthy good like sick people not in
therapy like healthy people in therapy i
think and people think that it's the
opposite but it
is yeah very true the do you do anything
um
outside of therapy like do you have any
rituals or like best practices for
yourself to kind of like ground yourself
center yourself work on cloudy thoughts
etc
i have
adhd
but that is like i have certain rituals
that i
sometimes do
um but i
yeah i think i just try to be really
nice to myself and that's something i've
tried to do my entire life and really
give myself
kindness and space and be the nicest
person to me always um so yeah just be
nice really really nice to yourself
that
beautiful sentiment beautiful sentiment
i'm curious too
what it's like um you know circling back
to
love victor that you went in on season
two
right
so what's it like
working and arriving on a set that
you're in the second season of when
everyone kind of knows each other like
how do you approach that
it was so wonderful and easy which is
nice i feel like anthony kayvon who
plays raheem and i were added in the
second season
and um
i think so we were kind of like you know
when like there's a new kid at school
yeah and it's like they're kind of
popular and everyone's like well then
it was very welcoming and nice and it
felt special and like the opposite of
like oh you're new so but they're like
come here
have you so that was really nice that's
beautiful
uh what do you do when you're not acting
or auditioning or working in
entertainment
oh
so little if i can
i know i like to watch tv i like to like
okay what do you watch
oh succession i mean i've been watching
that i just went to the
pen 15's newest season like premiere
thing which was fun and um that was so
good yeah it is so good but they're on
december 3rd
dropping the like
season 2 like 2b kind of because they
separated it because of cobin yeah um
and it's really
masterful it's like the best word i have
for it oh that's awesome
those girls are really genius um so i
love that show very cool what do you
do you enjoy going out to events and
carpet situations and things like that
yeah you do
do you not
i do fun
like i like it like alexis gets invited
like on like pr list to a lot of like
premieres and stuff and
it's really goofy like her and andrew
would do this thing where they would
like bring
like food like basically leftovers vibes
and pyrexes to like these like movie
premieres they would like get influenced
or invited to and then they would like
just like be there eating it and then
like
air dropping photos to strangers of
themselves eating it and like really
just like have fun with it like i said
like which i don't know
um i think if you don't take things too
seriously stuff is fun yeah yeah yeah in
federal more
um do you not like it it seems like you
hate events i
uh
i don't love them i love if you're like
kind of what you're saying if you go
with a great group of people that you
know you have like a core
group there then that's fun but the idea
of like going not knowing anyone is whoo
no thanks oh i would not wanna i don't
alone yeah unless i ha i have a reason
to be there but like if it's not my
movie then i would not be alone there
you go okay we're gonna take one last
break when we get back guess what uh
some more questions we'll be right back
[Music]
well
obvious question is
what's next what's coming up what's
going on because you've shot a bunch of
stuff in the pandemic which is wild to
me too yeah
it is wild um so next is honestly
finishing shooting season three of
victor um which has been fun really fun
so far and i think it's going to be a
special season um
and
we'll see what that means um
but yeah i have so i i did this netflix
movie this summer um which i think is
going to come around out around june
which is the same time love victor will
probably come out so that will be a very
like busy
month um but other than that like i mean
there's some like maybe stuff but
nothing really
concrete um just kind of being open
i would love to do something really edgy
yeah out there in case anyone's doing
you know
manifesting i've been doing some like
soft
you know more white content i would love
to do something like really edgy i did a
roll one time where i had a neck tattoo
in this movie it
um that's edgy oh blasphemy that went to
sundance but i had so much fun
and it was really edgy and
i'm kind of
wanting to do something like that yeah
very cool
um okay last little bit is that we get
questions sent in from listeners and
viewers some of them are advice some of
them are just straight up questions um
for you so here's one for you this
person writes that they're currently
watching survivor australia and they've
always wondered what they would do for
one million dollars
uh could i lie and betray my friends or
people i just met for the money so i ask
you would you lie and betray
for one million dollars
like it depends on what the level of but
my
first instinct is yes
because either
if it's strangers then it's a game and
they understand that there must be one
winner and then if it's my friends i
would probably like share the money with
them so
i would go yes yeah is there a reality
show that you would
be on or a game show
uh
yeah i would love to be on a game show
like a dealer no deal like type show
yeah yeah reality show makes me really
nervous um
i'm also not a reality head i have so
many friends who are like huge reality
show heads
i'm not so much i would want love to be
on um
what's the wayne brady show because i
love waiting oh let's make a deal yeah
that one
i feel like doesn't alexis get on the pr
list to be in the audience of that show
no she hasn't yet it's a big issue um
that's it for you guys
uh i also could see the two of you on
the amazing race i think that could be
very fun and also devastating i feel
like you guys wouldn't actually
participate you'd just be eating in
tupperware containers off to the side
um abel we've reached the end of the
podcast and it's been so lovely to talk
to you but before we wrap up completely
we like to give a little token of our
appreciation to our guest and that is a
personalized horoscope from us to you
that melissa is going to put in the chat
for you and when she does if you could
read it aloud to the class i don't know
if you're into astrology i actually am
okay cool well this is very an
unprofessional
horoscope
uh it says dear scorpio scorpion of the
stars i'm confused so we have a look at
here for the reading
um
the solar eclipse and the new moon will
be in sagittarius in your value zone
this weekend you'll be hit with strong
desires
for experiences and sen
truly like uh
sensuality like buying a really soft
shirt or tasting a definite meal just
make sure not to accidentally eat the
shirt or wear the meal in all that haze
okay it's a warning
yeah
it's a it's a misguided blessing it's a
word of caution it's good to know it's
good to know you know i think it's all
it doesn't hurt to read you know what i
mean exactly who knows what kind of
hidden guidance is between all the
gobbledygook exactly and it could be
like a dream thing where it's it's a
representation for something else and
later it's gonna hit me and it's gonna
make sense all the symbols the images
the metaphors they're all there
is that you said your cat's name is
confucius
yeah this is confucius
well i'm so glad that confucius showed
up for the little moment of zen at the
end here
he always does she pulls through
uh no ava where can people find you
where you want them to find you if they
don't know the only place um which is at
ava capri um and you can yeah watch love
victor season three
um when it comes out and uh yeah thank
you awesome
having such a nice time talking to you
yeah back at you thank you i can't wait
to see these dark dark comedies that you
get into in the upcoming years i will be
ready and
like i said when you get uh your office
hours going let me know i'm your first
client
let me let you know
thank you guys so much for listening
we'll see you next time on not too deep
goodbye too deep too deep too deep
not too deep with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
sound by chris henry and an extra
special thanks to flula for the theme
music